you may assume these equations efficient
so we're given displacement equation for
X and one for y as well plus so this our
horizontal vertical displacement so far
so good
okay now the next question it's a proof
question which is rather annoying once
you look me like there's no way it's up
lazy textbook writers okay it says
showed that the condition for the planet
goes to collide is this okay
so that's what they want you to prove
that if the particles collide this must
be true it must be true even though
other exceptions okay no you think about
it from this point of view namely this
equation they want us to prove it has
science in it right see you said not
that much to do with this and what to do
with this
so there's our first clue it's gonna
have something to do with this but what
does it mean for things to collide for
p1 and p2 so you collide really what you
need is for the x coordinates of one
particle to match the x coordinates of
the other particle at the exact same
time and the same thing for the Y
coordinates right you've got to have
them both together okay so if I take
this x coordinate right this is just a
general one so I'm gonna think about the
first particle p1 which starts over here
okay since this is general I just want
to make it concrete to this specific
particle so that doesn't require all
that much change since it's the
displacement horizontal spatial but
first particle I'll call it x1 right
that has an initial velocity of V 1 and
here instead of putting T for time as in
generally speaking
okay yeah no actually I'll leave it here
and I'll make it more specifically
tomorrow that's what I get for thinking
as I go so there's my first particle my
second particle is gonna look exactly
the same
almost right okay now for a collision
what am I going to want well at some
time and I'm gonna call it capital T
okay just to make it an actual constant
I just don't know what it is these two
should be equal to each other
yeah now there's a problem here this
equation works if you consider the
particle is beginning from the origin
okay now just looking at there which
would you call the origin what place
would you call the origin you really
can't pick anywhere most people
instinctively
they pick a as the origin okay because
that's what most of that questions look
like you start do you appreciate to
check that way now if that's the case
and this equation here is fine okay but
this one is not because the second
particle obviously is not starting at
the origin that's our first problem my
second problem is you look at this X 2
equals convention this is going toward
the right isn't it this is this is going
to be positive ok so not only is a
starting at the wrong place it's going
in the wrong direction so how do I
adjust this x2 equation so it actually
reflects where the origin
well I got it adjust two things number
one I've got to adjust its direction
okay so since it's firing in the
opposite direction I'm going to snap a
minus on the front okay so now it's hazy
left but secondly I've got to adjust
where it begins now it doesn't beat you
well if this is the origin okay then
whatever that distance is which I have
no idea what it is that's how far away
it begins okay
so sort of a conventional way to say the
length of an interval is to name the
interval and then slap on line over the
top
okay so just means so that's the real x2
okay so therefore at some point time T
these two should be equal to each other
right namely v1 capital T cause of my
first angle should be this
okay now this is one of the conditions
for a collision to occur okay but the
problem is I don't know what this is
sounds funny but I actually know what V
1 theta 1 V 2 and theta 2 are they just
love to fight for it but I know what
they are
whereas a B is actually indeterminate so
as a condition for these two particles
colliding it's kind of not really useful
to me like I need to know what a B is
before I can actually use that as a
useful condition so therefore that's why
this is going after these equations okay
so this is a little easier to do with
because even though they're standing on
two defenses horizontally vertically
this died in the same place right does
that make sense they're both side y
equals 0
so I actually can't use this equation
for both particles and I don't have to
adjust it in this way that I did before
okay
so therefore I can say for p1 and p2 to
collide now let's look at their Y
coordinates right y 1 will be minus half
GT squared the bus this part is just the
angle and the speed of rejection that
are adjusting and my other particle
attitude okay so just like before yeah
okay for a collision to occur at some
time T they have to be equal to each
other okay
so therefore I really shouldn't have
interleave beads but anyway you get the
idea
minus half GT squared this is going to
be y1 that's what I'm writing plus V 1 T
capital T that's the vertical position
and with first particle actually be
equal to the other one okay so that's
how we arrive at this equation okay we
think about what does it mean for this
to apply to our specific particles okay
and then I just equate them that's what
collision means that's what intersection
of years so you can see all I need to do
these two are gonna cancel out with each
other
and also this capital T I could just
divide through by its some positive time
so it doesn't matter what it is so
therefore that's how you get V 1 sine
theta-1 that's got to be equal to V 2
sine u okay with that I don't tell me
don't walk weird but this is actually
kind of exhibit of that's what you're
gonna get in an exam like here's a
result how can you prove it out of this
given situation okay and that's why it's
just that actually this is why this is
why you can only go for the Y value and
not the x value because you don't know
enough about the x value to say okay